wenn wir in diesem tag war diesen wochen
über das corona virus diskutieren dann
spielt china eine große rolle
wie sehen sie momentan die diskussion
auch aus den usa angestoßen was mögliche
kosten angeht die von china übernommen
werden müssen
also im moment sehen wir natürlich dass
es auch veränderungen bei den zahlen
gibt etwa dass die zahlen irgendwann
noch einmal korrigiert worden sind das
ist natürlich besorgniserregend
grundsätzlich glaube ich ist es jetzt in
der verantwortung der region sich
erstmal um die bekämpfung des virus zu
kümmern und dafür zu sorgen dass er sich
nicht weiter ausbreitet in der
geschwindigkeit dass unsere
gesundheitssysteme nicht überlastet
werden aber es gibt fragen die müssen
irgendwann beantwortet werden
das heißt die ursachenforschung es ist
ja auch alles wichtig wenn man einen
impfstoff haben will muss man ja wissen
wo das virus herkommen wie es entstanden
ist das heißt das sind alles fragen
geben müssen beantwortet werden und da
gehe ich davon aus dass china so wie es
ja auch öffentlich vertreten wird eine
konstruktive rolle dabei spielt haben
sie das gefühl wenn sie mit ihrem
chinesischen kollegen oder weiteren
regierungsmitglieder in kontakt sind
dass china tatsächlich eine konstruktive
rolle spielen will wenn man sieht dass
die zahlen nicht stimmten
wenn man sieht dass china sehr
wahrscheinlich zu spät informiert hat
eben über das virus haben sie der
hoffnung dass china sagen wir mal
ehrlich ist in der frage also ich habe
gerade vor wenigen tagen mit meinem
chinesischen kollegen noch einmal
telefoniert und im moment ist die
chinesische führung sehr konstruktiv
auch wenn es darum geht die versorgung
mit masken schutzausrüstung und so
weiter international zu koordinieren
aber es gibt fragen bleiben und die
müssen auch irgendwann beantwortet
werden und natürlich sind wir im kampf
gegen das virus darauf angewiesen dass
die zahlen die wir haben auch stimmen so
und was die ursachenforschung angeht
glaube ich haben wir haben alle die
erwartung dass jeder seinen teil dazu
beiträgt sehr transparent und das gilt
natürlich auch für china das ist das was
die chinesische führung ja auch
öffentlich proklamiert dass sie
transparent da wird umgeht
und das wird sie ganz sicherlich in den
die nächsten tage und wochen wird sie
anlass genug haben und möglichkeiten
genug haben das auch unter beweis zu
stellen aber wie finden sie es dass zum
beispiel gestern der wildtier markt in
oder der offene markt info an wieder
geöffnet wurde
das könnte ich nicht so recht
nachvollziehen das heißt sie sagen man
hätte den länger geschlossen halten
müssen wir eine debatte zb mit dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister in der
vergangenen woche gehabt er gesagt hat
man müsste auch darüber sprechen was zum
beispiel die hygienestandards angeht auf
vero ebene
er hat gesagt dass er persönlich noch
nie eine fledermaus suppe gegessen hat
und das auch nicht tun wird und hat die
diskussion gebracht dass das
international auch diskutiert werden
müsste was die hygiene angeht auf diesen
märkten also wer eine fledermaus suppe
ist oder nicht muss man glaube ich nicht
international diskutieren aber klar geht
es um hygiene wenn wir über eine
pandemie sprechen und wir wissen dass
das ja in anderen ländern anderen
regionen auch ganz andere kulturen gibt
und ganz andere ganz anderen umgang mit
hygiene und das halte ich für eine der
großen herausforderung wir wissen dass
sich ein virus ausbreiten kann und dass
das auch was mit hygiene zu tun hat und
wenn wir aber auch andere dafür sorgen
wollen dass in zukunft solche pandemien
nicht mehr entstehen dann hat das auch
etwas mit hygiene zu tun und da muss
jeder seinen beitrag dazu leisten und
dann muss man möglicherweise auch
kulturelle gepflogenheiten ändern das
tun wir ja hier auch wir gehen anders
miteinander um wir haben distanz wir
schütteln uns nicht mehr die hände
wir laufen mit masken durch die gegend
und das ist eine erwartung die ich an
alle habe und zwar an alle
eingeschlossen uns dass wir
möglicherweise von kulturellen
gepflogenheiten mit blick auf deren
hygienische auswirkungen uns in zukunft
vielleicht verabschieden müssen und
natürlich geht das auch für solche
märkte in asien
wir müssen lehren aus dieser krise
ziehen und es kann sich niemand darauf
berufen dass irgendwelche dinge bei
einem schon immer so gewesen sind und
deshalb irgendwann auch wieder so sein
werden
wenn das virus sich nicht mehr in der
form ausbreitet da habe ich schon die
erwartung auch nach china aber auch an
andere länder
dass jeder konsequenzen zieht und jeder
einen beitrag dazu leistet dass so etwas
nicht nochmal passiert denn im grunde
genommen ist es egal ob es in china oder
wo auch immer ausbricht wir haben ja
jetzt gesehen wie schnell sich sowas
weltweit verbreitet und da steht jeder
in der verantwortung da haben wir auch
eine erwartung gegenüber allen und zwar
nach allen himmelsrichtungen dass die
richtigen konsequenzen aus dieser krise
gezogen wird hat china auch die
verantwortung für diese immensen kosten
aufzukommen die durch die pandemie schon
jetzt entstanden sind
ich glaube es ist relativ illusorisch
darüber zu sprechen dass man wo auch
immer dieses geld von china eintreiben
kann man unabhängig davon bei der
ursachenforschung glaube ich sind wir
noch nicht so weit um überhaupt
abschließend sozusagen gerichtsfest fest
der zu können wo das entstanden ist und
wer dafür die verantwortung trägt das
hatte auch etwas damit zu tun ob es
möglicherweise fahrlässig der fall
gewesen ist also da brauchen wir
sicherlich noch etwas zeit aber zu
glauben dass die kosten einem land
aufgebürdet werden können das halte ich
für relativ historische wieso ist
illusorisch das wird uns alles unmengen
von geld kosten
die bekämpfung des virus unmittelbar
aber auch die wirtschaftlichen und
finanzpolitischen folgen mit denen wir
es zu tun haben mit dem was übrigens
viel länger zu tun haben werden als mit
der unmittelbaren bekämpfung des virus
das wird viel geld kosten und da werden
wir alle unseren teil dazu beitragen
müssen das ist ja eine debatte die zum
beispiel auch in der europäischen union
stattfindet und ich glaube wir haben
unter beweis gestellt dass auch wir
deutschland bereit sind und solidarisch
zu beteiligen insbesondere gegenüber den
ländern die ganz besonders hart
getroffen wurden herzlichen dank herr
maas für das gespräch bleiben sie gesund
und viel erfolg dabei die deutschen die
jetzt noch im ausland sind hier
zurückzuholen
vielen dank dankeschön